you should taste those guys this is like
a sex dessert stop saying sex like that
why just not a dirty word sex Kris
Jenner has a one-track mind
yeah you heard that right
sex in a sneak peek at Keeping Up with
the Kardashians Khloe and Kendall join
their mama for lunch
innocent enough right wrong it's nothing
but sex talk from the jump hey guys
sorry I'm late look how cute you look
thank you fabulous stick all over my
face
you know why oh I'm just having a little
makeout session in the car is that too
much Chloe's face is literally saying
what we're all thinking yeah and it gets
worse my shirt on right why would your
shirt not be on right just one of those
days like lipstick a mess shirt a mess
get it Chris why is it Cory here I
thought he was coming to lunch Cory had
to go home and sleep because we were up
all night you know how that goes again
please take note of Coco's face of
course that Cory is Cory gamble Chris's
longtime boyfriend I love our dynamic
with our mom and I would not change it
for the world
but does my mom overshare
I mean she's talking about her lipstick
being smeared her mojo just some things
the and then things get real weird
arimasu I heard it was the desert of
lovers I could rub this all over my body
now why would you want to press me I'll
just take your word for it Chris women
go through different stages in life and
I'm going through one of those stages
where I cannot get enough of my
boyfriend you've just got to get it in
win again couldn't be more opposite
right now and it's a little unfair that
I'm dating and having the time of my
life and Chloe's not Chloe and Tristan
Thompson split in February 2019
I'm it his cheating scandal with Kylie
Jenner's former bestie
Jordan woods you know things happen and
of course I'm sorry and apologetic as
much as I can be and you know and in
another clip from the new episode Chloe
says she's single and she's so not ready
to mingle are you dating anybody
no not even thinking about it no you've
been on a date no stop
well not since interestin and I broke up
yeah yeah I have friends like I want to
hook you up with someone I just don't
care I'm focused on myself and true
family that was what I do yeah
who knows maybe I'll never date again
khloe and khloe says she's doing just
fine on her own I just find it so
strange that people find it such a
negative when somebody wants to be
single trust me if I wanted to date I
would date I want to invest my energy
and my daughter and my self healing and
I think that should be really empowering
and it should be more rewarded rather
than frowned upon this is why Chloe is
my favorite Kardashian
I'm actually
fantastic and I think everyone has to
jump on this bandwagon this echoes what
Chloe told ET back in October you guys
have been through so much in your life
but what do you look what are you
looking for now you're not looking I'm
not but I'm not like in 10 I'm just
super happy and content and I'm focused
on work and like taking care of me my
body and soul and true and I just I'm
having so much fun with her and what I
want to I will it's not some deliberate
thing that I think that hard about
[Music]